la commune d'étang-sur-arroux se prépare
un événement spectaculaire ce jeudi et
même unique puisque cette commune de
1900 habitants va voir sa population
plus que doublé ce jeudi avec la venue
du président emmanuel macron il sera
accompagné de plusieurs de ses ministres
comme jean michel blanquer r le ministre
de l'éducation nationale ou encore
muriel pénicaud la ministre du travail
le président qui vient ici à la
rencontre des jeunes et ils seront
nombreux ce jeudi plus de 800 sont
entendus dans ce gymnase qui se trouve
derrière moi des lycéens triés sur le
volet qui seront du lycée bonaparte
d'autun du lycée militaire d'autun ou
encore des élèves de l'établissement
pour l'insertion dans l'emploi du volet
à étang sur arroux des élèves de cet
établissement qui sont en ce moment en
train de préparer ce gymnase d'y
apporter des chaises et de mettre des
barrières tout autour l'elysée n'a pas
souhaité donner d'informations sur le
dispositif de sécurité mis en place
mais ce que l'on peut vous dire c'est
que les personnes qui seront dans ce
gymnase ce jeudi sont triés sur le volet
il faut avoir une invitation pour entrer
dans ce gymnase pour le moment tout est
calme ici mais ce jeudi ce sera plein à
craquer